well we've heard far more from the  latest prime minister about cuts to  corporation tax over the summer than we  have about the cost of living crisis the  single most important thing that's  bearing down on so many millions of  households and that shows not only that  she's out of touch but she's not on the  side of working people so she needs to  deal with the cost of living crisis she  needs to deal with the fact that nhs is  on its knees and she needs to deal with  collapse of law and order and that can  be no justification for not freezing  energy prices  there's a political consensus that needs  to happen she needs to answer the  question how's she going to pay for that  labour made clear it needs to be a  windfall tax on oil and gas companies so  she needs to show that she actually  understands and can meet the challenges  that are there after 12 years of failure  of this tory government